[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission ne surtout pas
manqué si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local aujourd'hui c'est la
dernière émission de l'année nous sommes
sur notre 31 pour passer une heure avec
vous le programme lui ne change pas il y
aura des analyses techniques des
décryptages surtout une dose de bonne
humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau ils sont tous très élégants
présentation en musique de cette
magnifique dream team on commence à ma
droite musique c'est un grand sportif
qui a été notamment champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste master s'il est très
affûté mais attention à la période des
fêtes à ne pas se laisser aller il est
très élégant plutôt élégant bâtir le
capitaine
je suis en train de préparer les jouets
avec le Père Noël donc le petit lutin
c'est moi cette année
de Noël
vous rentrez en boîte de nuit c'est
merci on continue notre tour de table à
gauche musique elle est aussi très
élégante mais attention de vos pieds pas
son sourire d'ange c'est une très grande
sportive à la dent notamment la course à
pied mais elle s'y connaît dans tous les
sports à nous vient tout droit de Poissy
notre Wonder Woman Audrey le père est
avec nous bonjour Michael comment
allez-vous en pleine forme vous avez
sorti les paillettes j'ai mis la totale
là je suis prête pour les fêtes
au taquet toujours parfait vous avez
bien révisé j'imagine les missions
toujours toujours contrairement à vos
collègues on en dira pas plus autour de
la table oui enfin Yann oui encore vous
ça va ça va ça va pour le coup ça va on
repasse de l'autre côté musique tout le
monde le dit les fans le disent c'est un
mélange entre George Clooney et Russell
Crow mais aujourd'hui vu son élégance on
est obligé de dire qu'il ressemble à
George Clooney il nous vient tout droit
des contrées Versailles notre gladiateur
Pierre Chevalier du Rugby Club de
Versailles est avec nous et
très très content de terminer cette
belle année avec vous tous et en pleine
forme avant de prendre des formes je
pense à mon avis au pluriel dans cette
période qui est généralement un petit
peu moins propice à faire du sport
un petit veston rouge voilà déguisé en
sapin de Noël ou en Père Noël c'est solo
comme vous voulez les couleurs quoi
merci beaucoup George Clooney si on
termine de l'autre côté à musique c'est
notre Père Noël à nous chaque émission à
ses côtés est un cadeau il est notre
sucre d'orge notre étoile sur notre
sapin il est notre coach Jean Miss ex
entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
bonsoir à tous et à toutes comment
allez-vous
toujours bluffant toujours toujours
impeccable un petit Père Noël hein
de circonstances sur un gros Père Noël
[Rires]
parfaitement révisé les missions c'est
ça sur le bout des doigts sur le bout
des doigts et surtout dans vos spams
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons vous proposer un classement des
sportifs Yves Linois de l'année vous
allez connaître les fleuves de l'année
sportive dans les Yvelines mais avant de
parler de ces thématiques on va parler
de cette coupe du monde de football qui
vient de s'achever
[Musique]
la finale de la Coupe du Monde a rendu
son verdict est malheureusement la
France ne sera pas à championne du monde
pour la troisième fois la faute à
l'Argentine qui a gagné après un match
incroyable le score 3 3 4 tirs au but à
deux malgré un triplé de Kylian Mbappé
qui est passé par les Yvelines lors de
sa formation à Clairefontaine alors déjà
votre réaction sur cette finale comment
vous l'avez vécu Audrey pour moi
simplement la France a gagné
on a perdu effectivement penalty mais
pour moi on est arrivé du 3 au 3 si si
j'ai bien gardé le mal jusqu'au bout
avec les prolongations et on est resté
jusqu'à trois partout donc pour moi je
pense que la France a aussi gagné on a
perdu sur les Pneumatis je pense que
c'est par exemple
voilà et puis je pense que Hugo Lloris a
bien bossé je pense que simplement on a
perdu des tirs au but et on était
jusqu'au bout donc la France est allée
en finale donc belle belle fiertéro vous
êtes moins optimiste sur ce match de
l'équipe de France
alors on a vécu je pense l'un des enfin
pour mon âge de toute façon voilà et de
pour tous ceux que j'ai pu voir malgré
la première victoire de la France en 98
on a vu une des plus belles finales de
de Coupe du Monde depuis bien bien
longtemps maintenant je pense que on n'a
pas perdu cette finale ça c'est mon Moi
votre sentiment mon sentiment je ne
pense pas qu'on est perdu cette finale
pendant le pendant le match je pense
qu'on a perdu cette finale
il y a maintenant deux mois deux mois et
demi quand il a commencé à y avoir pas
mal de blessés dans les
incontournables de l'équipe de France je
pense à des Paul Pogba des Ngolo Kanté
voilà qui qui ont manqué cruellement
cruellement de leur expérience pour
cette finale je vais pas dire qu'il y
aura bio a pas fait un très bon mondial
bien au contraire mais
je pense que l'expérience de 2000 de de
aurait été
ça aurait pas été le même match avec
avec
du Monde 2018 avec nos absents voilà
Pierre Chevalier sur la finale la
question de la finale c'est j'ai vécu je
suis pas sûr je suis passé par toutes
les émotions en gros
avec avec à la fois à la fois une fierté
quand même on parlera du mondial après
mais sur la finale elle-même de la
fierté d'avoir été présent à ce à ce
stade là et d'avoir été capable de
défendre un titre de champion du monde
ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis les
années 60 et le Brésil en conservation
d'un titre de champion du monde après
la consternation en première mi-temps ou
ou en gros on la joue pas c'est-à-dire
que là là en gros il y a qu'une équipe
sur le terrain et on prend on prend
super cher sur la sur les 30 les 45
premières minutes 45 premières minutes
et et quand même malgré tout cet esprit
de révolte en deuxième mi-temps avec le
facteur X Mbappé qui est là où on
l'attendait c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a
suffisamment dit et remis en question sa
capacité à être prêt pour les grands
événements lui il le dit depuis toujours
il le dit que son objectif c'est la
Coupe du Monde il se prépare il enlève
tout ce qui peut le perturber là-dessus
sur une préparation de coupe du monde et
il est présent au final il en plane
trois plus son tir au but ça c'est un là
pour le coup c'est un coup de chapeau un
coup de chapeau monumental qu'on que le
peuple français doit lui faire et cette
chance que l'on a aussi de l'avoir de
l'avoir dans nos rang et puis après
évidemment la tristesse tristesse de
finir comme ça quand les tirs au but
arrive on sait qu'on est pas bon on sait
qu'on est que les finales au tir au but
on les perd la dernière contre l'Italie
de Greg canalé et puis et puis le le
c'est global incapacité à soit en
stopper soit en plaçait à chaque fois et
d'être et d'être imprenable au tir au
but donc sentiment mêlé au final au
final quand même un petit peu encore un
petit peu un petit peu triste
un peu vénère de l'avoir perdu celle-là
Jean vous aussi vous êtes triste non non
pas vraiment pas vraiment parce que je
vois pas revenir sur Mbappé parce que
tout le monde en parle donc c'est un
grand joueur il
a fait son job sur la fin par contre
faut pas oublier quand même je veux dire
un match de foot en l'occurrence
c'est 90 minutes c'est pas les 20
dernières minutes et les prolongations
et les tirs au but c'est pas ça là on a
une équipe de France qui a joué 20
minutes à la fin du match où elle a un
Mbappe qui effectivement parce que c'est
un grand joueur c'est enfin réveiller et
à montrer son vrai visage mais pendant
70 minutes
excusez-moi oui c'est regarder les
pompes quand même le type il a rien fait
quoi il a rien foutu on a eu moi j'ai
regardé le match où j'ai vu des
argentins qui étaient mais alors minable
qui qui se qui se mettaient minable qui
courait partout dans tous les sens qui
défendent des kataké j'ai même l'image
j'ai plus le nom du joueur mais j'ai
l'image d'un joueur argenté qui fait une
reprise de volley qui est belle que
Lloris arrête il y a une relation de
l'équipe de France qui c'est qui vient
défendre à 60 mètres d'où ils viennent
faire la reprise de voler c'était
l'Argentin c'est quand même une image où
on a tourné tomber sur une équipe
d'Argentine et je crois je l'ai vu tiens
je l'ai vu ce matin je l'ai même pas vu
cette vidéo là Deschamps à la mi-temps
ce qu'il est ce qu'il dit dans les
d'aller dans les vestiaires il dit mais
mais on a une équipe qui eux joue une
finale
il dit et nous on ne le on ne joue pas
et c'est ça que alors bien sûr moi moi
le premier les les je veux dire après
vers 70e minutes à c’était magnifique on
oublie quand même les 70 premières ou on
sait où on s'est merdé quand même où on
a vu qu'une équipe d'Argentine sur le
terrain et on a vu des joueurs de
l'équipe de France qui était quand même
plus que passif et qui se regardait un
peu les pompes et à ce niveau là
ça pardonne pas c'est tout moi je trouve
qu'on a eu même de la chance qu'on a eu
la chance d'arriver à faire trois trois
parce qu'on a un joueur comme Mbappé qui
est un peu un joueur qui est un joueur
hors du commun mais sinon mais sinon
c'est s'emballer c'est 2-0 on en parle
plus si on a pas Mbappé c'est 2-0 on a
parlé donc euh ils étaient tous malades
sur la première mi-temps j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes tous malades
oui après je rejoins un petit peu ce que
ce que tu dis Jean sur la première
partie il faut aussi savoir que en face
les Argentins ils ont un jeu hyper
agressif moi j'ai trouvé que
effectivement les Bleus étaient plus ou
moins présents moi mon chouchou c'est
Griezmann donc j'ai vu qu'il était
partout il a aussi
je l'ai très bien suivi et c'est vrai
que en face les Argentins étaient très
agressifs donc j'ai trouvé jeu des des
Bleus hyper en fait très malins très sur
la défensive effectivement les Argentins
ils ont fait que des fautes moi c'est
l'arbitre j'ai pas compris son jeu sont
état d'esprit s'il y avait effectivement
une volonté de pouvoir enfin favoriser
l'Argentine puisque la France ça c'est
déjà un arbitre qui laisse jouer de
toute façon très
régulièrement les jouets sur toutes les
non mais c'est ça
je veux dire c'est ça enfin ouais on
savait que cet arbitre pouvait laisser
jouer sur sur beaucoup de contact mais
il fallait mettre du contact et les
Argentins l'ont fait on ne l'a pas fait
il y avait aucune agressivité c'est
jouer sur tous les contacts le premier
penalty notamment l'Argentine sur ce
pélestataire
pour la France c'est la même action
c'est la même action donc ici je veux
les deux qui sont de même contact on
peut en parler pendant une heure c'est
pour ça que le problème c'est qu'il faut
avancer dans les dans l'émission alors
on va revenir sur les performances des
de nos imminois il y a plusieurs joueurs
qui sont passés par les Yvelines qui
étaient dans ce groupe France on va
commencer par Kylian Mbappe on va pas
revenir dessus mais on va quand même en
parler un petit peu il est passé par
Clairefontaine dans le sud des Yvelines
entre 11 et 2013 il a marqué 8 buts en 7
matchs les meilleurs buteurs du Mondial
avec un ratio de 1,14 but par match il
devance Messi qui a marqué 7 buts en 7
matchs il a également fait deux passes
décisives alors votre avis sur sa coupe
du monde à Mbappé très rapidement parce
qu'on en a déjà parlé on valide
mais à comparer à comparer un de ces
entre grands joueurs on avait un messie
d'un côté à 35 ans on avait un Mbappé à
23 ans mais si c'est quand même beaucoup
plus quand même
c'est un joueur qui qui fait ce qu'il
dit c'est-à-dire qu'en gros il s'était
derrière rendez-vous là-dessus on peut
critiquer ça préparation et ce qu'il a
rendu comme copie avant que ce soit en
équipe de France ou avec le PSG mais au
final sur les grands rendez-vous le mec
nous fait gagner il fait il fait en gros
il maintient et là je te rejoins
totalement si on l'a pas si on l'a pas
c'est bonsoir de 0 et c'est et personne
ne pleure mais si on l'a pas on est même
pas on est même pas là en 8e de toute
façon parce que il y a quand même une
chance les buts
sur une coupe du monde là il est en
train de de coupe du monde pour la
France avec deux avec en deux Coupes du
monde il est en train de il est en train
de monter en flèche dans les dans les
stats il est en train d'affoler les
statistiques mais c'est c'est
4 ans donc est-ce que il en aura
d'autres finalement on l'a vu très déçu
à la fin du match il y en aura d'autres
il y a du genre bah oui minimum 2 parce
que ça fait 32 pour 24 28 28 32 donc ça
fait 32 pour la prochaine pour les deux
la vraie pour les deux suivantes bien
sûr qui va en avoir encore et s'il joue
jusqu'à 36 il aurait 35 ans d'ailleurs
parce que là il a il a il a 20 ans
mais comme le trois rôles est dans 3 ans
et demi donc il pas 35 comme comme Messi
pour sa cinquième Coupe du Monde
maintenant il sera obligé de changer son
jeu parce qu'aujourd'hui il est
énormément basé sur la vitesse à 35 ans
il ira certainement un peu moins vite
aussi donc
ici mais si j'ai pas trop l'impression
qu'il va moins vite le garçon non mais
aujourd'hui il les a tous à fond
aujourd'hui la qualité première
Mbappé c'est sa vitesse il devra nourrir
son bagage pour pouvoir continuer de
rester à ce niveau là c'est tout il va
devoir devenir de plus en plus technique
parce qu'il y a un moment où la vitesse
il va la perdre mais il veut à de toute
façon c'est quand même un joueur qui a
du ballon qui a été du ballon
la phase alors on va maintenant parler
du duc je parle bien sûr de rabiot le
joueur de 27 ans a peut-être réalisé
c'est meilleur prestations sur le
maillot bleu il a été formé au PSG il a
grandi à Saint-Germain-en-Laye il avait
notamment marqué contre l'Australie il
avait fait une pas décisive alors votre
avis sur la Coupe du Monde de Rio
validé révélation
Audrey je vous donne la parole ensuite
il y a je sens que vous êtes très raview
vous autour de ce plateau
on l'a vu se développer physiquement
aussi dans sa technique dans son jeu et
aussi je pense dans son examen était un
garçon coach et je pense qu'il s'est
vraiment développé c'est vraiment
affirmer aussi et de pas aussi sa
situation familiale personnelle le fait
qu'il ait perdu son père je pense que
c'est lui donner encore plus de volonté
de pouvoir encore mieux mieux jouer je
pense sur le terrain et d'avoir
effectivement cette cet état d'esprit
beaucoup plus engagé beaucoup plus
vraiment comment est-ce qu'on dit
vraiment hargneux et on dit
effectivement il y a un terme très
combatif et en fait il lâche rien sur le
terrain et c'est vraiment si tu as
l'esprit enfin moi je l'ai vu vraiment
il y a longtemps plus jeune et là
maintenant je vois une vraie différence
donc oui belle révélation et bravo à lui
de s'affirmer comme ça
pour pour vous Audrey palauvert pour
vous aussi oui parce que parce que c'est
en plus bon il reste jeune Adrien rabiot
20-25 ans 26 grand max hein
il faut pas oublier une chose c'est que
c'est quand même un gars qui a une qui a
souffert dans le début de sa carrière
son départ du PSG avait pas été si
facile que ça dans des conditions où il
avait été mis au placard pendant une
période à cause de à cause de sa cause
de sa maman
tout à fait et alors pareil concours de
circonstances il est là parce que il y a
du monde qui a sauté mais bon il était
de toute façon sélectionné dans les dans
les dans dès le départ mais c'est vrai
qu'il a plutôt en tant que remplacement
et là il a vraiment augmenté son statut
et pris une pris une place prime place
au milieu mais son volume de jeu de
toute façon il a augmenté depuis qu'il
est parti jouer en Italie et je pense
que bon le titre de 2018 on le doit à
l'Italie faut pas l'oublier ce qui est
ce qu'il faut souligner pour compléter
c'est le c'est justement le rendez-vous
qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a respecté en
remplacement avec joamini de quand même
Pogba et Kanté
là c'est pas évident de remplacer au
pied levés de monstres de monstre comme
ce comme ces deux-là qui nous ont fait
gagner en 2018 comme comme il y en avait
rappelé et finalement dès le premier
match contre l'Australie il plante et il
passe décisive et en gros c'est c'est
effectivement le une révélation ou une
confirmation en disant que que le gonze
il est là il est là il est il est il est
dans l'écran pont du remplaçant mais du
remplaçant finalement en remplaçant de
luxe et qui est devenu qui est devenu
très rapidement intitulé il peut être
titulaire sur la durée à votre avis Jean
pour moi oui parce que c'est plutôt ceux
qui étaient absents qui vont être
obligés de remontrer qu'ils étaient
indispensables
voilà parce que là c'est bien beau mais
lui il fait une belle coupe du monde
donc pourquoi l'enlever
il a un excellent niveau actuellement
donc pourquoi la lune je pense que c'est
plutôt des joueurs comme au Portugal qui
vont être obligés de de revenir pour
revenir au point de vue et lui et lui
reprendre la place quoi enfin il y a
Matéo Guendouzi le joueur originaire de
Poissy qui a été formé au PSG le joueur
de 23 ans a vécu sa première Coupe du
monde et il a juste joué le match contre
la Tunisie la seule défaite de l'équipe
de France 1 à 0 alors votre avis sur la
Coupe du Monde de Matteo Guendouzi vert
ou rouge
rouge pour vous Pierre Chevalier rouge
pour vous Yann Dujarier malheureusement
vous êtes partage du côté à gauche sur
la gauche un petit duel entre Jean et
Pierre allez votre Jean-Pierre chier
alors
Matteo voilà Mathéo donc on va vous
validez sa coupe du monde mais
est-ce qu'on peut valider le pauvre il a
pas pu s'exprimer quand il a pas joué
beaucoup il a pas joué beaucoup il a
joué lundi les conditions où c'était le
match où je dirais que tout le monde
enlève le pied et puis notre emplacement
dans le
11e mais on savait que c'était déjà joué
que c'était déjà qualifié neuf
remplacements sur 11 bon et on peut pas
on peut pas le juger sur sur je dirais
pas que c'est pas une mise à mort mais
presque c'est à dire allez vas-y va
jouer toi maintenant et puis on enlève
tout le monde allez vous amuser bon et
ça fait partie ça fait partie du groupe
il est dans le groupe il a joué il est
il a failli être champion du monde
pardon monsieur
c'était juste pour taquiner
chef du gang des coiffeurs non seulement
par sa coupe de cheveux mais aussi parce
qu'on statut donc les coiffeurs ce sont
ceux qui accompagnent le groupe les 26
puis 25 puis 24 parce qu'on a eu faut
pas oublier ça aussi on a quand même eu
deux blessés et deux abandons en cours
en cours de matchs de poules donc en
tant que que représentant star du groupe
des coiffeurs il aurait dû saisir sa
chance pleinement sur le match de la
Tunisie pas évident ça c'est une
évidence
de l'équipe de sur 10 et en fait non
seulement il est pas au rendez-vous mais
en plus il fait peut-être une de ses
pires performances en équipe de France
on a en face on a la Tunisie qui joue
qui joue sa vie ampoule pour encore
espérer éventuellement se qualifier mais
bon a priori c'était déjà c'était déjà
plié dans cette poule mais justement
c'est c'est dans ces moments-là qu'on
voit si si le joueur est au rendez-vous
si techniquement il est il est prêt
c'est physiquement il est prêt si
surtout dans la tête il est prêt et là
il est passé complètement à côté avec un
certain nombre de joueurs aussi du
groupe qui complétait donc des
remplaçants les remplaçants de luxe du
groupe France mais donc il est passé
complètement à côté de la plaque et là
effectivement c'était pas forcément un
service à lui rendre mais c'est aussi ça
une coupe du monde tout le monde
participe s'il avait si on avait été au
bout il aurait été champion du monde et
on aurait retenu on aurait retenu on
aura pas retenu sa prestation contre la
Tunisie bon là on en parle oui
effectivement rendez-vous raté donc une
coupe du monde qu'il faudra oublier et
lui aussi il en aura d'autres à jouer et
je pense qu'il sera il sera bien mieux
au rendez-vous à ces moments là on va
dire match nul entre Pierre et Jean sur
cette thématique
on continue à pas cette coupe du monde
n'est plus précisément de l'avenir du
PSG après cette coupe du monde mais si
et Mbappe vont-ils pouvoir jouer
ensemble en attaque les deux joueurs se
sont un peu chauffés pendant la
rencontre et surtout les Argentins ont
beaucoup chambré Mbappé que ce soit dans
les vestiaires ou lors des célébrations
du titre en Argentine le gardien
Emiliano Martinez à défilé avec une
poupée à l'effigie de Mbappe sur le bus
des messies étaient juste à côté un
apparemment mais s'il ne l'aurait pas vu
selon les journaux argentins la question
sur cette thématique vont-ils réussir à
jouer ensemble pour le PSG PSG qui bien
sûr a planté dans les Yvelines au Camp
des Loges à Saint-Jean-de-Monts
actuellement et qui va déménager bientôt
à Poissy
oui pour vous tous
Viane pour vous c'est ça oui
dithyrambique
c'est un oui parce que
parce que j'aimerais foncièrement que
Kylian Mbappé gagne la Ligue des
Champions avec le PSG avant de partir
voilà tout simplement donc comme il
reste que cette année
partira pas cet hiver il partira à l'été
prochain mais partira pas cet hiver ça
c'est ça c'est ça c'est sûr
et puis que comme Messi ne reste que
cette année il finit son contrat à la
fin de l'année il y avait une année en
prolongation mais je pense qu'il y a peu
de chance qu'elle soit qu'elle soit
faite donc bah oui j'aimerais que que ça
se fasse cette année et que Paris
remporte la Ligue des Champions malgré
mon cœur mon cœur sudiste mon cœur mon
cœur blanc est blanc et blanc et ciel
mais c'est vrai que ouais je trouve que
c'est
pas l'Argentine je parle de Marseille
mais c'est vrai que ouais je trouverai
je trouverai ça bien que qui puisse
accrocher cette cette Ligue des
Champions avec avec le PSG avant de
partir parce que ouais parce que c'est
un gamin qui le mérite de toute façon
c'est il est il est enfin il est déjà à
l'entraînement là il est déjà à Paris il
est déjà pris l'entraînement quoi
il est il est il est irréprochable
celui-là il aime le foot bien sûr pierre
si c'était Martinez ce qui était au PSG
là la question était elle aurait été
vite répondu maintenant c'est ce sont
deux professionnels l'un est rentré
encore plus dans sa légende mais si avec
un titre de champion du monde qui lui
manquait donc encore un peu plus dans la
légende Argentine et puis finalement la
légende du football mondial
petite parenthèse son son compte
Instagram a été a été le plus notamment
son poste sur la finale elle était le
plus liké de l'histoire de toute
l'histoire d'Instagram dixit Mark
Zuckerberg donc c'est c'est dire un
petit peu Laura et le et l'audience que
dont Messi bénéficie
Mbappe il a plus le temps il a il a il a
11 ans d'écart par rapport à par rapport
à Messi ils vont ils vont se retrouver
au PSG ils se sont un peu chambré
sportivement sur le terrain en Coupe du
monde ils se sont challengés en fait
le Messie en première mi-temps Mbappé en
deuxième ils se sont rendus coup pour
coup mais c'est resté je trouve c'est
resté fair-play et sportif comme deux
légendes de leur pays et de coéquipiers
en club
Mbappé il a il a il a il a l'avenir
devant lui heureusement pour nous
français il a il on l'a avec nous et je
pense que que avec les échanges qui
arrivent et notamment en Ligue des
Champions surtout si Martinez signaux
Bayern pour le pour la suite de la
compétition en Ligue des Champions ça
doit être marrant c'est ils vont pouvoir
après mettre de côté peut-être des
frustrations et les joies de chaque côté
et puis tirer dans le même sens pour le
PSG parce que il doit pas leur rester
grand temps à jouer au PSG ensemble ni
pour la ni pour l'autre donc c'est
peut-être cette année ou jamais Audrey
tout d'abord bon anniversaire Killian
parce que c'est c'était le 20 décembre
donc déjà c'est comme un sacré cadeau
avant de parler de de Killian et de
Messi moi je suis très contente que ce
soit Messi qui qui gagnait cette coupe
au-delà de la France c'est une très
belle représentation auprès de cette
nouvelle génération des valeurs qui qui
développent et qui communiquent je
trouve vraiment très porteur de sens
en plus enfin voilà c'est une belle
image aussi au niveau mondial après la
question c'est est-ce que Messi et qu'il
y a de lumière s'entendre oui parce que
ce sont deux joueurs professionnels mais
alors la question c'est qu'il y en Aymar
aussi au PSG est-ce que Neymar va être
jaloux est-ce qu'il a facilement
peut-être influencé qu'il y a à dire bah
écoute tu peux partir maintenant du PSG
est-ce que parce que Neymar et Messi
s'entendent plutôt bien est-ce que
peut-être que Kylian aura envie de
partir peut-être du PSG donc c'est aussi
si on rajoute brésilien dans
l'adéquation lui il va rendre le moral
il l'a vraiment très très bas
qui sont pas très très bien du coup ils
ont pris une grosse grosse claque dans
la gueule parce que Mbappé Mbappé en
finale mais il réussit globalement
sondial oui mais voilà on était un peu
de recul c'est pas c'est pas un mondial
raté on est allé jusqu'en final le
Brésil
super tôt quoi donc là le la la
quart de finale contre la Croatie
est tellement important chez un joueur
en tout cas au PSG donc je pense que
Kylian encore beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à prouvé il est encore très jeune
je pense que voilà il y a encore des
choses à prouver il y a 10 ans devant
lui si il part du PSG ce sera pour une
bonne raison mais j'espère qu'il partira
pas à cause de Neymar de Neymar Neymar
lui taper dedans il a effectivement le
provoquer je pense et je pense que ça
sera peut-être un duel enlever Neymar
reste mais qui change ta esprit en tout
cas
est un bonheur d'homme et un bon
entraîneur
très rapidement est-ce que vous dans un
monde pour moi la coopération c'est ce
que vous pouvez mettre Messi Mbappe dans
le 11 titulaire en ce moment oui mais la
coopération a bien fonctionné cette
première partie du de notre championnat
au PSG contre un petit peu l'année où
c'était je le foutoir là ça a bien
fonctionné la coopération c'est bien
passé avec des résultats comme l'a dit
Pierre c'est pas ils se sont jamais mais
c'est sportivement dans un bon état
d'esprit parce qu'on a affaire à deux
garçons de d'un grand talent et très
intelligent donc pour moi il y aura pour
moi on essaie de mettre un problème là
où il y en aura pas voilà et puis il est
mort ça changera pas quand même il a
toujours été comme ça donc lui il va
revenir comme il a toujours été donc il
y a longtemps lui qui m'a pris une tarte
dans le museau le rôle de l'entraîneur
de pouvoir effectivement l'aider à
grandir
Mbappé aujourd'hui à l'entraînement
Neymar est toujours en vacances pour la
petite anecdote
on va passer à la prochaine thématique
le PSG affrontera le Bayern le 14
février prochain 8e de finale de Ligue
des Champions et il y aura sûrement
Mbappe neymar et Messi à la tête de
l'attaque parisienne on continue notre
thématique sur la Coupe du Monde on va
parler de l'engouement dans les Yvelines
après des débuts timoré la Coupe du
monde à réuni des fous les notamment
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a eu 6000
personnes dans la structure pour la
finale les supporters sont passés par
toutes les émotions on l'a dit il y a eu
ce type de scène un peu partout dans les
Yvelines au total 24 millions de
personnes au minimum ont suivi cette
finale de la Coupe du monde meilleur
audience en France pour une finale alors
la question sur cette thématique cet
engouement pour cette Coupe du Monde au
Qatar
est-il vraiment une surprise
est-ce que cet engouement est une
surprise pour cette Coupe du Monde au
Qatar parce que quand on voit ces images
là on voit on voit 24 millions de
personnes un vélo de trompe plein craqué
6000 places
pour vous mais non
c'est l'engouement il est pas monté il
est monté tout simplement parce que
l'équipe de France a fait des bons
résultats si l'équipe de France avait
été éliminé en quart de finale comme le
Brésil contre l'Angleterre et ben
l'engouement ne serait jamais arrivé et
voilà là à partir du verre de finale en
effet il y a un moment où Ben l'esprit
sportif prend le pas sur sur les
convictions que que tout à chacun
peuvent avoir après des histoires de
boycott aussi
que je voulais préciser c'est que c'est
qu'en gros c'est c'est le avant et après
et le pandorant et les deux les deux
parties s'opposent c'est ce serait
définir si d'un côté on avait les
politiques et si les sportifs étaient
eux un peu politique versus les
supporters là en gros on a vu assez vite
même des les matchs de poules que toutes
les tous les avis qui pouvaient qui
pouvaient se dresser contre le
l'organisation de cette Coupe du Monde
au Qatar en gros petit à petit avait
perdu un petit peu de leur superbe et
que de toute façon à partir du moment où
ce mondial était attribué au Qatar il y
a déjà bien longtemps c'est là qu'il
aurait fallu vraiment vraiment donner de
la voix au fur et à mesure après
l'être humain est faillible et en gros
donner donner du spectacle et du sport
et du sport au peuple comme comme dans
la dans la Rome antique et finalement et
c'est là où ça se passe et donc cette on
avait besoin de cette de cette chaleur
de cette ferveur et en plus l'équipe de
France à performé est allé jusqu'en
finale donc il y avait tout qui était
réuni pour évidemment peut-être au
départ un petit peu
même pas dès le match d'ouverture à la
limite le premier match France Australie
on va voir peut-être à Bois-d'Arcy et
pas forcément beaucoup de monde je sais
pas si on peut voir les images genre
premier match il y avait pas beaucoup de
monde
alors le match d'ouverture le match
d'ouverture le premier match d'ouverture
on va la voir l'équipe de France ouest
le premier match de l'équipe de France
regardez regardez c'est pas forcément
plein à Bois-d'Arcy en bois 6000
personnes au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin lui pour la finale
et là c'est c'est le premier match de
l'équipe de France mais ça c'est
purement français quand même tout le
monde devait boycotter et France
Australie quand même il y a un record
d'audience pour le match France -
Australie il faut pas l'oublier donc
personne n'a boycoté comme la vie pierre
c'est le coupe du monde qui s'est
déroulé normalement et les gens ont
suivi l'évolution et les performances de
l'équipe nationale et puis on regardait
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude elle
engouement a été exactement le même et
si ils avaient été champion de France ce
n'était le feu en France euh du monde
merci champion du monde
qui a été le même en 98 oui oui pire que
ça je sais pas me faire de toute façon
pour moi pour moi ça a été pareil que
d'habitude Audrey oui c'est en fait il y
a deux sujets il y a effectivement c'est
un effet de mode le fait de pouvoir
boycoter le match franchement ça ni que
ni tête pour moi Yves comme la dit très
bien pierre c'est en amont qu'il faut
boycotter effectivement on est conscient
de ce qui s'est passé lors des
constructions du stade voilà la
logistique la sécurité c'est bien passé
c'est aussi ça qu'il faut aussi
souligner après le fait que tout le
monde puisse se rassembler autour du
sport moi je c'est plutôt porteur
d'autant plus avec ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité avec le covid avec
effectivement on m'a dit entre
guillemets les l'économie et les l'écart
qui se fait je pense qu'il faut rester
quand même assez concentré au tout du
sport que toutes les coutures puissent
se retrouver et faire la fête il faut
rester positif et effectivement que le
chef d'État Vienne soutenir la France
c'est porteur de de toute manière comme
la très bien dit aussi
pardon j'ai oublié ton prénom
et non mais c'est pour le taquiner aussi
le père Noël tout simplement pour pour
dire que il aurait été là ou pas là
qu'on boycotte ou qu'on ne boit pas les
Français sont là toujours pour se
plaindre donc ça il faut aussi changer
de mentalité ça va être je pense et
c'est un gros challenge pour les années
à venir il va falloir effectivement
avancer ce soit au kata ou dans une
autre ville et ça aurait été pareil
ça va déjà être une catastrophe là faut
savoir que en effet c'était au Qatar
mais tous les trois ans et demi
excusez-moi tous les tous les tous les
stades étaient dans un rayon de 150 km
je crois
dans trois ans et demi Canada Mexique
États-Unis voilà avec avec 12 ou 16
stages je sais plus enfin voilà ça va
être plus d'équipe je crois 48 et 48
équipes mais ça va être ça va être un
bordel monstre il va falloir au niveau
logistique pour les équipes ça va être
une ça va être une catastrophe donc oui
en effet on aura le cadeau d'en parler
mais et alors attention petite
ingrédient c'est que finalement comme il
a pas fait si chaud que ça au Qatar les
clims n'ont pas été autant utilisé que
que ça dans les salades voilà mais ils
avaient ils faisaient trop froid dans
les stades donc elles ont été arrêtés
donc voilà il y a eu des choses qui ont
été mises en place et qui ont été mises
en place peut-être
pour trop bien faire et qui n'ont pas
utilisé et qui ont amené du moulin à la
polémique qui finalement n'a même pas eu
lieu d'être j'entends rapidement passer
la prochaine thématique attends des
nouvelles de la supportrice croate
et non mais non
elle est gonflée
une belle transition en tout cas
[Musique]
on va maintenant passer à notre volet du
jour notre emblématique Grégory quelle
année n'est pas avec nous sur ce plateau
pour cette dernière malheureusement
notre Italian lover est parti en
vacances il en avait bien besoin après
une Coupe du Monde éprouvante pour lui
avec la non qualification de l'Italie
cette année il nous donne son palmarès
des sportif de l'année dans les Yvelines
on l'écoute salut la team si on parle
les sports j'espère que vous vous portez
bien malgré la récente des fêtes de
l'équipe de France en finale de la Coupe
du monde de football alors que la fin de
l'année arrive à grand pas il convient
de regarder désormais dans le
rétroviseur et de faire le bilan qui est
le sportif yvelinois de 2022 voici
quelques propositions mon choix de
l'année dernière Arthur rinderknech et
en 2022 encore le tennisman mérite de
figurer parmi les nominés il fait forte
impression des envies en Australie avec
une finale au tournoi d'Adélaïde et un
premier tour de haute volley à
l'Australian Open rinderknecht c'est
aussi à juger le tournoi challenger de
Poznan a été peut appeler régulièrement
en équipe de France de Coupe Davis le
saint-germain-nois termine même l'année
dans le Top 50 du classement ATP et
surtout comme numéro un français et que
dire de Caroline Garcia après des mois
d'errance la Renaissance une première
demi-finale d'un Grand Chelem dans sa
carrière c'était à l'US Open 4 titres
rien que ça cette année la native de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye réussit le tour de
force de remporter le master WTA une
première pour le tennis français depuis
Amélie Mauresmo en 2005 et Garcia
conclut même l'année comme numéro 4
mondial on attend la suite avec
impatience lui est à 18 ans l'une des
attractions du sport mondial Victor
Wayne bagnat de mettre 21 elle dit sa
dernière danse avec le championnat de
France le basketteur de 18 ans est
premier à la NBA les franchises vont se
l'arracher lors de la prochaine draft ça
ne fait aucun doute en attendant celui
qui a été formé à l'entente Le Chesnay
Versailles a changé de club cette saison
passant de l'ASVEL de ton Parker au
mètre 92 de l'entraîneur est
sélectionneur français Vincent Colette
avec succès si ton son mois de novembre
exceptionnel 132 points inscrits
sélectionnez pour le All-Star Game de la
LNB et cerise sur le gâteau une première
cape avec l'équipe de France elle
justement étant en pleine histoire
d'amour avec les Bleus Émilie Boulard a
connu sa première Coupe du monde de
rugby avec le 15 de France féminin en
Nouvelle-Zélande c'est d'ailleurs face
au blackfirds vainqueur de la
compétition que les Tricolores ont
échoué à une seule marge de la finale en
2000 du Mondial mais Emily Boulard et
ses coéquipières sont montés tout de
même sur le podium un rendez-vous durant
lequel la suivelinois s'est
définitivement imposé comme la numéro 15
des Bleus deux essais inscrits et
quelques passes décisives elle sera même
élue meilleur joueuse du quart de finale
face à l'Italie enfin enfin Mathilde
gros est sur le toit du monde de sa
discipline en octobre la piste est
devenue à 23 ans championne du monde
deux vitesses la communion était
incroyable avec son public au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Yvelines une
demi-finale empochée au caractère et au
terme d'un suspense insoutenable face à
l'Allemande et mindsup avant de ne faire
qu'une bouchée d'une autre allemande en
finale Léa Sophie friedrique son premier
sacre mondial qui donne fin pour la
suite et on a déjà hâte d'être en 2024
pour les JO avec de nouvelles épreuves à
domicile mais mon sportif yvelinois de
l'année il n'est pas seul c'est un
collectif que j'ai voulu distinguer et
qui d'autre que le Football Club de
Versailles pour marquer les esprits en
2022 un parcours onirique en Coupe de
France les Yvelinois se sont tissés
jusqu'en demi-finale du Trophée de tous
les possibles là où le terme Petit
Poucet prend tout son sens au tableau de
chasse du FCV notamment les pros de
Toulouse je me souviendrai pour ma part
de se déplacement à votre compagnie
Mickel à Périgueux auprès des supporters
c'était pour le quart de finale face à
Bergerac et au-delà de la Coupe de
France c'est la saison 2021 2022 qui est
incroyable avec une montée en National
en point d'orgue aujourd'hui les
Versaillais sont deuxième du championnat
et se prennent à rêver de la Ligue 2
allez la team j'ai même une proposition
à vous faire Versailles ville sportive
de l'année 2022 dans les Yvelines
j'oublie pas non plus la montée
historique des rugbymen en Fédérale 2
voilà c'est la petite dédicace pour toi
mon Pierrot j'ai un petit footing à
faire donc je vous laisse et je vous
souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année salut
a toujours aussi élégant notre Grégory
canal
vous êtes dans le top
dédicace
pas suffisant en tout cas pour Grégory
pour vous mettre comme sport au même
niveau que le Football Club de
Versailles mais oui c'était c'était il a
il a raison de dire que pour Versailles
ville sportive de l'année c'était une
très très belle année est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec Grégory le FC
Versailles numéro 1 cette année dans les
Yvelines sportif de l'année dans les
Yvelines non pour vous il y a du Jarrier
et oui pour vous Audrey donc vous c'est
ok on va on va déjà parler avec vous
Audrey donc pour vous c'est OK jusqu'au
bout c'est oui effectivement ils ont
encore du chemin à faire il y a encore
une marge de progression à faire on est
d'accord mais Méline toujours oui
toujours présente
les 5 6 et Yvelines quand même oui oui
c'est vrai
qu'il faut mesurer et je suis désolé oui
ok ils ont fait une demi-finale de Coupe
de France
c'est du foot donc du coup ça prend plus
de place et sincèrement en regardant le
classement de de Grégory
bien sûr que mon cœur irait pour
Mathilde de gros parce que championne de
championne du monde et champion du monde
en plus dans les Yvelines à 50 ans à 50
ans en Yvelines donc du coup c'est vrai
que ça rajoute surprise un petit peu un
petit peu mon repassage mon mon petit
bébé mais ce que Caroline Garcia a fait
mine de rien c'est aussi une très très
belle saison je n'avais pas j'avais pas
du tout intérêt comme ça par contre pour
pour Arthur ringertess mais alors je
suis pas du tout d'accord il a même pas
passé un tour à Roland-Garros il est
meilleur Français évidemment français
cette année c'est ridicule place mondial
et il a même pas sa place donc dans le
dans le classement donc voilà je suis
peut-être un je suis peut-être un petit
peu dur mais il fait il nous donne
personnes sur janvier plein d'espoir et
il y a zéro confirmation sur la suite de
la saison rien du tout donc je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment dommage il a juste
passé un tour à fléchis de medo donc
donc voilà c'est c'est pour moi c'est
pour moi un flop plutôt sur cette année
et les fleuves on va en parler juste
après mais voilà je pense que pour moi
les viennoises de l'année ce serait plus
car une Garcia qui avec un master avec
un avec un master bah ouais c'est une
c'est vraiment un beau un beau résultat
surtout que le tennis français est quand
même en grande difficulté depuis très
longtemps Pierre Chevalier je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec hier
exactement
dans le classement de Grégory mais en
fait dans le classement des sportifs des
Yvelines il y a beaucoup de femmes ça
c'est et pour je pense que si on si on
on
précise je pense qu'on n'avait pas
autant au moins pas autant que ça et et
à ce niveau là et moi ce que ce que
j'aime dans dans l'épopée de Caroline
Garcia c'est que c'est extrêmement
français c'est-à-dire que c'est la on va
dire la perdante magnifique ou la
seconde magnifique qui qui fait SAMU qui
sort de sa chrysalide et qui qui prend
tout le monde de surprise elle avait
elle avait très mal commencé sa saison
et puis elle a commencé en janvier
finalement des titres comment ça tombait
jusqu'au Master et là là pour le coup
avec un avec un plateau extrêmement
relevé parce que il faut voir aussi les
oppositions qui a alors en Coupe de
France en Coupe de France de foot oui
oui il y a du seuil il y a du sérieux
mais ce sont des équipes et en
individuel pour Mathilde gros ou pour ou
pour Caro Garcia il y a du monde en face
et là au niveau mondial en cyclisme ou
au tennis il fallait quand même aller se
le peler ce Masters et personne ne
l'attendait et c'est une très belle
championne avec en plus une abnégation
et un esprit elle aussi a connu
d'inconnu des grosses galères à titre
individuelle et en équipe de fait Cup
pour le coup pour le coup la gros coup
de chapeau pour moi c'est c'est la
révélation et donc la sportive de
l'année par rapport à ces résultats
et pour moi
le sportif de l'année
pour deux raisons la première parce que
je m'étais promis de pouvoir prononcer
donc je l'ai fait ça a marché Victor
apparemment aussi
et la deuxième parce que oui
c'est un garçon qui mais qui est très
jeune et qui a une marge progression
énorme et qui a mon avis il va devenir
un très très grand champion
c'est moi le champion parce que il a eu
une marge progression énorme et puis là
ben c'est parce que c'est par rapport il
a lui malheureux il a pas le choix de la
date et c'est un peu tôt par exemple
parce que lui et ben il a dès l'année
prochaine il va être tout le monde va se
l'arracher aux États-Unis donc on peut
dire que c'est trop tôt pour lui mais
pour moi c'est mon sportif de l'année je
précise qu'il a que 18 ans
monsieur Michael
cinq fois
de mettre 21 pour
victorité
sportifs Yves Linois de l'année bon il y
a eu des tops ça on a tous dit autour de
cette âme mais il y a aussi des flops
dans les Yvelines j'ai quelques
propositions à vous faire je sais bien
que ça ne va pas plaire aux sportif
concernait mais il faut aussi le dire
pour qu'il puisse rebondir
qu'y a-t-il
mais on est obligé on est encore sur les
nominés des sportifs Illinois mais des
flops mais je suis pas d'accord du tout
avec les avec les je ne suis pas
d'accord avec les tops mais je suis pas
d'accord avec les flops non plus parce
que vous connaissez déjà les flops c'est
pour ça alors en premier lieu Louis
Burton il a une nouvelle fois dématé
avec son IMOCA Bureau Vallée sur la
dernière Route du Rhum c'est la deuxième
fois que ça lui arrive en un an après
son dématage sur la Transat Jacques
Vabre on est très déçu parce que Louis
Burton a terminé troisième du dernier
Vendée Globe et c'est un ami je le
précise donc je peux être dur avec lui
il y a aussi il y a aussi un boxeur dans
les flops Tony Yoka originaire de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes il a perdu pour la
première fois de sa carrière en mai
dernier face à Martin bacollé il avait
jusque-là 11 victoires dans 9 par k.o à
30 ans il est redescendu au classement
il pourrait ne jamais devenir champion
du monde chez les lourds en cyclisme sur
piste Sébastien Vigier et Ryan Elan les
pista et Vinois n'ont pas réussi à
briller à domicile au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin lui lors des derniers
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste on attend beaucoup de pour les JO
de 2024 mais ils sont passés à côté
enfin j'avais noté en golf le versaillé
de 29 ans Antoine Rosner qui n'avait pas
gagné cette année sur l'européenne tour
belieblinois a gagné juste avant cette
émission le moritius open avec 5 coups
d'avance donc il a de la chance il reste
un demi flop du coup sur cette saison on
voit les images magnifiques images de
Antoine Rosner avec son trophée donc
les demi-flops et les demi-flops pour
moi demi-flops je suis le responsable de
l'émission pour moi il est demi-flop
alors qui est pour vous le flop de cette
année
vous votez donc oui Burton Tony Yoka
Sébastien Vigier Ryan et Lalle ou
Antoine Rosner
genre d'abord
je plaisante non tout simplement parce
que ben on en a beaucoup de discuter
autour cette table pour moi il avait
quand même pas rencontré un challenger
on va dire
de pointure de pointure jusqu'à le
dernier jusqu'au dernier et il est pas
passé et là il a 30 ans 30 ans pour moi
ça va être très très difficile de
pouvoir aller essayer de briller un
titre champion du monde donc c'est pour
moi c'est c'est le flop de l'année il a
raté il a raté son rendez-vous son grand
rendez-vous c'était quasiment le seul on
sortait un petit peu des bouchers de
quartier ou des videurs de boîtes de
nuit comment lui disait à chaque fois
mais là quand même bon
qui s'énerve pas après moi mais bon il a
pas eu de chance quand même il est très
loin
il se pète la boxe il est blessé au pif
dans la semaine qui précède de combat à
la banque du coup voilà c'est vrai que
quand j'avais vu la liste je m'étais dit
oui c'est vrai que le cas c'est une
grosse déception mais sur le combat il
reste il va au bout du combat alors
qu'il est blessé au début du combat et
que en effet il le paye il le paye sur
le combat donc pour moi pour moi je
resterai sur sur Bureau Vallée
on va parler d'abord peut-être de Tony
yokai et ensuite on verra pour les
autres c'est simplement une des
rendez-vous ratés et c'est des effets
d'annonce qui sont aussi mal mal
maîtrisé depuis son passage depuis son
passage en pro c'est un c'est un
champion olympique qui avait qui avait
le l'avenir au moins olympique amateur
devant lui très grand champion de deux
boxe dans ces dans ces différents
combats et là son passage son passage en
pro il y a eu il y a eu différents
télescopages d'annonces d'engagement de
Paris fait sur l'avenir et puis
effectivement de de d'opposition qui
n'était pas qui n'était pas à son à son
niveau supposé et il y a eu dans la
promotion de ces combats une absence de
choix dans la date régulier et lui il a
quand même dû s'aligner et va coller la
ramener à la réalité froide violente du
du de la box de la box mondiale et la
box professionnel donc oui par rapport à
tout ce qu'il avait dit faire ou
s'engager à faire et le résultat et puis
là c'est parti dans les oubliettes on
n'a pas de date on n'a pas il y a pas de
il y a pas de combat à tenir il y a plus
rien bon ouais flop
oui en fait dans le sens où il a
effectivement eu pas mal de défaites
mais en même temps on a tellement
soutenu et encore une fois faut aussi se
dire qu'est-ce qui va se passer après
peut-être après une défaite on peut
avoir peut-être éventuellement une
victoire il faut aussi peut-être se
projeter ça peut toujours toujours
intéressant de revoir le changement
pour se remettre à
sel pour aller pour aller gratter un
titre ça va être juste ça va être chaud
hein donc surtout que les leaders de la
catégorie on ne marche que lui
donc Tony Oka du coup fait partie de vos
gros flops de l'année dans les Yvelines
obligé de m'inscrire en faux
effectivement mais vous l'avez vous
l'avez bien bien fait sur sur Antoine
Rossner bien évidemment qui est qui
n'était pas au rendez-vous de ces
derniers résultats de 2021 et 2020
j'apprécie ce que je l'avais mis entre
lui entre les deux qui gagne cette
émission il gagne Maurice de très belles
manières et là pour le coup les
perspectives sont complètement
différentes ouais j'avais appelé juste
avant je lui ai dit tu seras dans les
flops si tu gagnes pas
la Bible donc
sa dernière victoire
je le mets je le mets dans les flops
parce que au Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin
champion d'Europe cette année et on le
met dans les flops non mais c'est juste
hallucinant quoi vous avez juste pensé
qu'il y avait une compétition 50 ans de
vie et une saison c'est plein je prends
l'aspect yvinois je vois que dans les
Yvelines il n'a pas performance
désolé c'est Mathilde de gros qui est
vinoise de sportive puisqu'elle était
champion du monde à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors ce
n'était pas mon avis c'était celle de
Grégory donc bon donc
soyons soyons soyons réparer Sébastien
on peut pas le mettre dans les flops
Ryan je ne oui Ryan Ryan je vais pas je
vais pas dire le contraire parce qu'en
effet il était je crois mais je sais pas
si tu vas me laisser pour échapper à
d'Europe enfin voilà
il y a rien eu non plus donc
oui Ryan je suis d'accord mais Sébastien
je suis pas du tout d'accord en
Sébastien Vigier et Ryan et là le
finalement ce sont
quoi ils sont déjà les prochains
Sébastien il a 24 Sébastien 24 ans on
vient juste de dire que comment
non non pas
non plus
devant lui donc voilà il y a le même âge
c'est bon et faut pas non plus faut pas
abuser donc là je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vous c'est pareil encore
10 ans devant eux en mon nez faut
laisser un peu la place l'espoir
champion olympique de kering à 36 ans
voilà donc il est jeune Audrey on le met
pas dans les flops ils sont jeunes tous
les deux champions
je remets une couche sur le cette
émotion qui nous a procuré en citant le
Rugby Club Versailles bien sûr avec
cette montée et cette confirmation on se
débute saison ou le RCV figure bien dans
sa boule de Fédérale 2 et de Fédérale B
qui n'a pas été du tout envisagé pour
les flops en tout cas le rugissement
un mot peut-être sur Louis Burton aussi
on en a vite fait ce qui fait quelques
mots
c'est ça c'est le gros flop
c'est c'est pas ses qualités ses
qualités professionnelles qui sont de
navigateurs qui sont remis en cause là
c'est un problème technique il peut rien
c'est le bateau oui bon après quand le
pilote de chez Ferrari quand la Ferrari
elle marche pas on dit que c'est quand
même le pilote qui qui qui va pas bien
le championnat du monde
donc là moi je suis je suis je suis très
déçu parce que c'est vrai que ça te
course cette course du coup pour moi la
durée 3 jours alors que je m'attendais à
faire un à faire un 8 8 10 jours là de
fiesta toutes les nuits pour aller
vérifier les résultats et tout j'ai j'ai
eu une grosse une grosse déception parce
que ouais j'attendais cette Route du
Rhum avec avec impatience et ça fait ça
fait flop pour moi très rapidement
enregistré ça sera le nouveau dévoilé
l'année prochaine
donnez-moi la cassette
cette émission alors on va peut-être
faire un petit tour de table peut-être
pour sauter de bonnes fêtes spectateur
de tv78 Audrey on commence par vous quoi
donc un corps un esprit sain dans un
corps sain avant les fêtes et surtout
après les fêtes donc je vous donne
rendez-vous l'année prochaine et puis
bah on espère qu'il y aura des nouveaux
talents sportifs en 2023
un petit mot peut-être pour les
téléspectateurs de tv70 vos fans vos
nombreux fans de fin d'année avec
modération attention soyez sages n'avez
pas trop et puis à l'année prochaine
Pierre Chevalier formez bonheur à tous
que l'année 2023 soit encore plus belle
que 2022 et plein de choses pour le golf
le rugby
il a déjà rien et ben 45 minutes de
footing et vous serez en forme pour
pouvoir digérer les petits excès des
petites des petites soirées ou des ou
des repas du midi minutes avant ou après
le repas
après vous pouvez y aller après voilà de
le lendemain le 2 jours après c'est pas
c'est pas un souci attention
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose une citation de Zinedine Zidane
les performances individuelles ce n'est
pas le plus important on gagne et on
perd en équipe je vous laisse méditer
sur cette phrase très belle fête de fin
d'année sur TV 78
[Musique]